Traduttore: Maria Pericleous
Revisore: Greta Longobardi
Tempo fa, il giornalista
Massimo Gramellini
pubblicava un brevissimo
ma illuminante pezzo
sulla Stampa,
in cui raccontava di un nonno
che aveva conservato
in cantina uno scatolone
pieno di lampadine ormai bruciate.
Perché era assolutamente convinto
che in futuro si sarebbe trovato
il modo per ripararle.
Il giornalista si chiedeva dunque
quando e perché
abbiamo smesso
di credere nel nostro futuro.
Forse abbiamo smesso
di credere nel nostro futuro
quando abbiamo smesso
di credere nella scienza.
La storia, si sa, va a cicli.
Nel 1818 Mary Shelley scrisse questo libro
che secondo me incarna perfettamente
il passaggio da Illuminismo
a Romanticismo.
Dalla fiducia nella scienza
tipica dell'Illuminismo
alla visione negativa
che invece della scienza
aveva il Romanticismo.
Qui lo scienziato è visto come un folle
e la scienza come qualcosa
di mostruoso e pericoloso.
Ebbene dopo i grandi progressi
scientifici e tecnologici del Novecento
oggi siamo di nuovo
in un periodo buio per la scienza.
Ho deciso quindi
di condividere con voi questa sera
una riflessione circa i passi da compiere
per poter ricominciare
a guardare al nostro futuro
con ottimismo.
Il primo passo consiste sicuramente
nel dire un forte NO alla pseudo-scienza.
Perchè ho detto che siamo di nuovo al buio
lontani dai lumi della ragione
perchè la società è sempre piú scettica
nei confronti della scienza
e i suoi metodi
e si affida sempre piú spesso
a charlatani e imbroglioni.
Potrei parlarvi del recentissimo
caso Stamina
o delle tante cure miracolose
contro il cancro
che chi sa perche, secondo alcuni
vengono tenute nascoste.
Ma invece ho deciso di raccontarvi
qualcosa che ormai è storia.
La tragica storia del DDT.
Vedete il DDT è stato il primo
insetticida moderno
e a partire del 1939
esso è stato usato su larga scala
per combattere la malaria
con risultati strepitosi.
Al punto che nel 1948
esso valse il premio Nobel
al suo inventore Paul Müller.
I fatti appunto parlano da soli.
In Sri Lanka, per esempio,
si passò da 3 milioni
di casi di malaria all'anno
prima del uso del DDT
a soli 18.
E la National Academy of Science
ha stimato che il DDT in meno di 2 decenni
è stato in grado di salvare la vita
a 500 milioni di persone.
Ma cosa accadde?
Accadde che nel 1962
una biologa Americana Rachel Carson
scrisse il libro Primavera Silenziosa,
Silent Spring divenuto un Best Seller,
nel quale sostiene che il DDT
sia pericoloso per l'ambiente
ma sopratutto che sia
un cancerogeno per l’uomo.
L'opinione pubblica, allarmata,
cominciò ad esercitare forti pressioni
e l'idea che il DDT
fosse davvero estremamente pericoloso
per la salute dell’uomo
divenne un dato di fatto.
Senza tuttavia nessuna prova scientifica
a sostegno di questo.
I governi, sulla spinta
dell'opinione pubblica,
e nonostante il parere contrario
degli scienziati,
decisero di metterlo al bando
con conseguenze drammatiche.
In Sudafrica si ebbe un aumento
del 1000% dei casi di malaria.
e si stima che la messa al bando del DDT
abbia causato finora
la morte di 50 milioni di persone.
E ancora oggi nel mondo di malaria
muore un bambino ogni minuto.
In tanto la scienza è andata avanti
e ha prodotto i suoi dati,
i fatti. E ha dimostrato
che il DDT non è un cancerogeno.
Al punto che recentemente
l'Organizazione Mondiale della Sanità
ha dichiarato che il DDT si può utilizzare
perché non é pericoloso
per la salute dell’uomo.
A questo punto chiediamoci
quanto ci è costato questo errore.
Questa strage silenziosa
poteva essere evitata?
Io penso di si.
Se si fosse stati in grado di distinguere
tra vero e falso.
Tra scienza e pseudo-scienza.
Ricordandosi che la prima si basa su fatti
mentre la seconda su opinioni.
E attenzione perchè in questi giorni
stiamo ricadendo negli stessi errori
con la storia dei vaccini.
Di nuovo assistiamo pericolosamente
ai fatti che vengono calpestati
dalle opinioni.
Ma come fare quindi a distinguere
un fatto da una menzogna?
Nello stesso modo in cui distinguiamo
un quadro falso da uno vero.
Solo attraverso la conoscenza.
Se io non conoscessi Leonardo,
il suo stile, la sua pittura,
non sarei assolutamente in grado
di dire quale tra questi due dipinti
sia l'originale.
Ecco dunque che la strada per capire
se ci stanno mentendo
se ci stanno vendendo fumo
passa attraverso un avvicinamento
alla scienza e i suoi metodi.
E questo mi porta immediatamente
al secondo passo da compiere
per riconquistare il nostro futuro.
Bisogna aumentare il capitale scientifico
del nostro paese.
In Europa da anni viene monitorato
l'alfabetismo scientifico
attraverso una serie di domande
che vengono poste alla popolazione.
Il sole è un pianeta?
Gli antibiotici uccidono virus e batteri?
L'elettrone è più piccolo dell'atomo?
Ebbene solo il 60% degli italiani
è in grado di fornire
una risposta corretta.
Contro oltre l'80% degli Svedesi.
E questo significa che 2 Italiani su 5
non sanno che il sole è una stella.
O che gli antibiotici
servono solo a combattere
le infezioni batteriche.
In Italia solo il 3% della popolazione
conosce il metodo scientifico
contro il 78% dei Finlandesi.
Siamo quindi un paese
scientificamente analfabeta.
Nelle scuole, ma già a partire
dalle scuole elementari,
bisognerebbe investire molto più tempo
nell' insegnamento del metodo scientifico.
Perché solo attraverso
un esercizio costante
all'analisi razionale dei fatti
si potrà poi sviluppare
quella capacità di affrontare e risolvere
i problemi usando la logica.
La mancanza di capitale scientifico
nel nostro paese
si riflette nel basso numero
di ricercatori che abbiamo.
In Italia, il numero di ricercatori
in percentuale sulla popolazione
è molto più basso
che in Francia e in Germania
E non a caso - questo dato correla
con la percentuale
di investimenti rispetto al PIL.
Terzo e ultimo passo quindi
per poter aumentare
il capitale scientifico del nostro paese
distinguere cosi tra vero e falso
e guardare di nuovo
al futuro con ottimismo
è investire nella ricerca.
Ma in particolare nella "Slow Science",
la ricerca di base.
Ricerca di base che si sa
non va più di moda.
E del resto è normale
che una società che abbia smesso
di credere nel proprio futuro
non sia minimamente
interessata alla ricerca di base
le cui ricadute non sono mai immediate.
In un mondo dominato dalla fretta
fatto di fast food
anche a scapito della qualità
fast news, anche a scapito delle fonti
ecco che si chiede anche
alla ricerca scientifica
di essere fast, veloce, finalizzata
applicata e pronta a mettere
sul mercato un prodotto.
E ci si dimentica troppo spesso
che la ricerca applicata altro non è
che l'applicazione della ricerca di base.
Ma tutte le grandi idee
sono nate grazie al gioco, alla curiosità
alla continua partita a scacchi
che appunto noi ricercatori
giochiamo ogni giorno con la natura.
Rentgen di certo non pensava
alla mammografia
quando, giocando, ha scoperto i raggi X.
Così come di sicuro Einstein
non aveva in mente il GPS
quando studiava la relatività.
Ci sono voluti molti anni
prima di trovare le applicazioni pratiche
a queste enormi scoperte scientifiche
mosse soltanto dalla curiosità.
Rivendichiamo quindi il diritto a giocare
a prenderci tutto il tempo che ci serve.
A non twittare i risultati
dei nostri esperimenti.
A sbagliare, confrontarci
e ammettere di aver sbagliato.
Rivendichiamo il diritto
alla lentezza, ad una scienza accurata
libera da pressioni
e svincolata dal mercato.
Abbiamo iniziato questa chiaccherata
con una lampadina rotta.
Simbolo, però, di un futuro luminoso.
Perche noi questa lampadina
la vogliamo riparare.
La scienza non è un nemico.
Grazie ad essa
la vita media dell'uomo
è passata da 38 anni a 83.
E questo è stato possibile
solo grazie al progresso scientifico
e tecnologico del Novecento.
Perché è lì che in pochissimi anni
la vita media è quasi raddoppiata.
E ancora oggi,
grazie al progresso della scienza,
la mortalità infantile per cancro,
per infezioni, continua a diminuire.
E dunque in questo futuro migliore
che noi dobbiamo e vogliamo
continuare a credere.
In un nuovo Illuminismo.
Che è poi l'arma migliore
che possiamo usare in questi giorni bui
contro chi vuole farci ripiombare
in un violento e assurdo Medioevo.
(Applausi)